"The mobile phone is a kind of extension of my body."
Mobile phones know yourself better than yourself, in fact, they are exaggerated.
a fact
Do you remember that you have been to the sidelines every day?
Do you remember that you had a single letter on February 29th with a score of 10:47 and Friend?
Hey! If you are serious, you will remember that you have a generous holiday.
Black and white writing, low human history, has been in the ancient Egyptian era
Deaf people will Feel to hieroglyphics
Your phone can count down millions of sheets of paper.
To a certain extent, the same amount of generosity will become the same level of generosity.
Since you bought the raft, there is a moment when you only hold your hand to the channel.
A great opportunity to blame you for your life.
Hey, you pick: You want to read people, and let the people call you?
If you are deeper, you should pick the former.
Contrast back to your brain and the buried mobile phone to remember your brain, actually remembering it, and there is a mistake
It’s easy to remember that you have a lot of money on your phone.
Because there are too many realities, you simply remember to dry
When people are stunned, you think it’s safe.
Actual facts
When the mobile phone has become my body extension, I know that something is happening.
Your brain will eventually become mandatory, just like a family phone.
Do you want to escape? You will become...
If I protect the most intimate electronic equipment (legal sample)
My generous future will become a good horror
Because the law is like a brick wall, the law will be overlaid on the previous law.
So sometimes you will hear lawyers quote 300 years ago
And because of the system of the shackles,
So it’s awkward to start building bricks in a new place.
Because of the bricks, the 唔 is the invincible brick wall
Refuting "the regulation is only a case, it is time to use curry" as much as refuting the legal department.
It’s like a chess game that tells you about it. "Because I want to take your army afterwards."
All of them are talking about 唔通咖, all are
300 years ago, someone wrote about the house business
However, when the squadron is on the half of the population, the paper is the same as the luxury of the book.
After that, you can apply millions of intangible files to your mobile phone.
Record every detail of your life
Maybe you feel good. Or okay. But the points are good. "After the fight, the law will overwrite the previous legislation."
One is to solve the problem, to pay attention to the legal precedent
With the burial point, the landslide is misunderstood.
Thinking about today’s generous law, that is, thinking about the future of the law and burying your mobile phone
Inevitably thinking about your future